[Music]
the topic of abortion never seems to go
away and I want to talk to you as
someone of science and as an atheist who
obviously has no morals how how do you
negotiate this because it seems to me
that people on the Left when they talk
about abortion they make it sound like
everyone on the right hates women and
that they want to control women and when
people on the right talk about it they
make it sound like everyone on the left
hates babies and that's right and
neither one of those things you know
that's very obvious so how do you as
someone that comes to conclusions based
on science how do you navigate the sort
of ethical I assume you're pro-choice
but actually I'm just assuming that but
is that no of course I so how do you
then as someone that's pro-choice mm-hmm
believes in evidence believed in science
how do you decide where like do you
think that it should be a two-month
cutoff for an abortion where where do
you come up with that as someone that
isn't coming from the religious angle
but is coming from the science-based
angle I'd say abortion should be legal
up until 12 years old probably like
until the brain is fully known yeah um
actually that'd be more like 20 guys
that's gonna take off um you know it's
funny because I am an evidence-based
thinker I try to be an epidemic ER and a
skeptical thinker and I try to listen to
the science first and then make my
political decisions based on that so I
am liberal yeah I am left-wing I am
progressive I think it's easy to paint
me in but I'm also super Pro vac
mandatory vaccinations I'm Pro GMOs
which is usually a more conservative
viewpoint so sometimes it's hard to put
me in a box
now I'm not pro like I am pro-life I
hate that term it makes it sound like
I'm not yeah I'm I am pro-choice not
because it's partially because of the
science and it's partially because I'm
not religious and I think that a lot of
pro-life ideology comes purely from
religion and once you take religion out
of the equation it becomes a much more
nuanced and complicated topic I am
pro-choice meaning that I don't think
that if a woman wants to have an
abortion she shouldn't be able to and I
don't think that if a woman wants to
keep her baby she should be coerced to
have an abortion I think
that a woman should be able to make a
decision based on her own body and in my
view which may sound kind of extreme
until that baby is born it's hers it's
her body right so I agree with you I
guess up until that point I'm absolutely
pro-choice but but about a week before
the birth I mean we're you know I know
that gets into just raw man argument
yeah it doesn't happen right it's like
it's like the voter ID stuff you know
like Oh voter fraud we got to be careful
about that
women don't carry babies to a week to
term and they go I think I'm gonna lose
this big right it's a book but so at
three months when the baby now has
features and you know all these things
and I guess this is the slip actually up
to this point it's it's legal first and
second trimester abortions are legal and
I think that you have to look at all
this is the thing when you're writing
laws we have to think about not just the
obvious cases but the aberrant cases
this is why writing legislation is
actually a very you know it's a nuanced
and artistic endeavor and especially
then when you look at how you defend
laws in the courts right when you look
at case law it's complicated because we
have to fully understand all of the
times when the when the laws can be
misused or misinterpreted and there are
cases for example where a woman does not
know that she is pregnant until well
into her pregnancy and I think you do
have to take that into consideration
there are cases in which women are
victims of coercion or abuse or
sometimes it is more nuanced than that
maybe they feel pressure from their
husband their boyfriend or a member of
society to have a baby and they don't
realize until later that they do have
these options maybe they fall on
financially difficult times maybe they
find out that there's you know some sort
of genetic abnormality and the baby and
that they don't have the means to raise
that baby and I think that all of those
really complicated really emotional
personal questions have to be taken into
account I want to say and it may be it's
easy for me to say because I don't have
kids but the woman is the vessel and she
is carrying this child and until the
child comes out of her it is her body it
is her choice and they are her rights
and I do think that it's a complicated
topic and I think that that's why it's
important that we do talk about it and I
know and I agree with Ramona I almost
regret having said the part about the
one week before birth because because I
know it is a straw man and it's not
something that happens but I think
there's something interesting about the
when is it really a feasible life thing
that and obviously we can't resolve that
now and I think that we have to think
about every possible option because even
religious people you'll you'll find that
whereas they would be appalled if they
got knocked up and had abortion they
might go get IVF which some religions
don't even allow that but they might get
IVF and of course they're going to do
selective reduction during IVF is that
not abortion and interview I mean it's
very complicated yeah because you know
sometimes you do IVF and like five of
them stick yeah and then you turn into
Jon and Kate Plus
[Music]